I've peeled back the curtain at the risk
of not getting reelected I have
explained a lot of the evil that happens
in Washington DC I've been that person
who stands up objects at that point they
hate you for breathing air Kentucky
congressman Thomas Massie is a thorn in
the side of the GOP establishment this
bill's not even written are you kidding
me and we're supposed to vote on it
tonight that's why I'm a he'll know he's
voted against so many bills including
those championed by his own party that
in 2014 Politico dubbed him mr. no I
will not sugarcoat this this is a
disappointing day for us I didn't come
to Washington to make friends I came to
Washington say yeah well they saved the
country elected to Congress in 2012
during the height of the Tea Party
movement Massie is also an mit-trained
engineer with 24 patents to his name who
founded a pioneering tech company
specializing in 3d scanning and touch
computing he drives an electric car and
lives with his family in an off-the-grid
farmhouse which is the subject of a new
documentary Massey is an
environmentalist who co-sponsored
legislation last year to disband the
Environmental Protection Agency solar
panels may be the energy source of the
future he says but that doesn't mean we
have to mandate or subsidize their use
reasons Matt Welch recently sat down
with congressman masse at Freedom Fest
in Las Vegas to discuss his battles with
the Republican establishment how Trump's
tariffs are breeding cronyism and the
impact he and his fellow libertarians in
Congress are having on policy
congressman Massie thanks for joining us
say for having me
so a couple weeks ago I was at the
Libertarian Party National Convention
and just talking to people and a lot of
people brought up your name you're one
of their favorite people along with your
pal Justin Amash and even some people
said it'd be great if Thomas Massie
maybe ran for the Libertarian Party
ticket in 2020 why are you a Republican
when so many libertarians like you look
there are a few libertarians in Congress
and we've all got ours next to our name
there are some Democrats who get close
on some issues like jared Polis will
break away from the party on some
libertarian issues and Justin and I are
basically always on our own track which
is
mostly libertarian by the way a mediocre
libertarian makes for a great Republican
I mean ultimately at the end of the day
we're trying to shrink the size and
scope of government and that fits inside
of the Republican platform with some
allowances here and there yeah the
allowances seem to be very spending
notwithstanding spending spending not
with NSA spying notwithstanding right
like as soon as Republicans control
everything in government just spending
spending seems like it's perfectly fine
Katie bar the door what is the positive
case for someone who considers
themselves libertarian at least half
libertarian I don't know exactly how you
described yourself Oh along those lines
but what's the positive case for working
within the Republican Party as opposed
to in the libertarian party or just
outside flapping their arms around it
well the non partisan politics the
difference is you can get elected as a
Republican and then you can actually go
to the floor of the House of
Representatives and vote that's not to
say there isn't a place for Big Al
libertarians there's something in
Congress that as we're voting we call
true north and occasionally we all know
that we deviate from true north every
now and then I would like to think that
Justin Amash and I and Rand Paul and
Mike Lee are pretty close to true north
most of the time maybe 10 degrees off
but the the libertarian party I think is
is good to have because they come up
with the most morally balanced
principled rational basis for the
decisions that we make in government and
those would be true north just to be
clear are you here ruling out a
presidential run in 2020 for the
libertarian party
I am absolutely rolling out a run for
any office in 2020 as a big al
libertarian very good now so you
mentioned and as you do in conversation
often the same names come up a lot it's
you Justin Amash Rand Paul Mike Lee
first of all are there other names on
the list there are occasionally
occasionally you get surprised I've
backed candidates to come to Congress
and everyone that I've backed it's
pretty much sold out
within a few months of coming to
Congress a Jew named name says fine dad
you go see who I've backed I don't have
a good track track record in fact I tell
people they don't want my endorsement if
they wouldn't get elected and not sell
out let me give you a name of somebody
who's come to Congress and really
surprised us Andy Biggs from Arizona huh
if you see to nose on a on a bill its
428 2 to the to nose will be most often
me and Justin Amash if you see three
it's now Andy Biggs and he's doing it on
a constitutional basis he recognizes
when we when the Republicans are voting
for bigger government and he doesn't
fall for it what do you feel like that
you have accomplished since coming into
Congress not just you you but you're a
group of small group of friends they're
like what tangibly do you feel like that
the world is a better place because you
are up there either saying no or trying
to say yes on some things the main thing
that I think I've contributed in my time
in Congress is an unprecedented level of
transparency
I've peeled back the curtain at the risk
of not getting reelected I have
explained a lot of the evil that happens
in Washington DC and how it is broken
because what I see back in the states
and back in our districts are solutions
that won't really fix the problem
because they a lot of folks don't
understand what the problem is for
instance some people want a
constitutional convention to rewrite or
add to the Constitution the problem is
not that we need a new constitution the
problem is that my colleagues don't
follow the Constitution we have so I'm
not in favor of constitutional
convention a lot of people think that
term limits will fix things term limits
might nibble around the edges but if
fundamentally not going to fix what's
broken in Congress the problems are
bigger than that so one of my
contributions I feel is to go out there
and explain and no uncertain terms how
that place is messed up so that the
folks back home can dial in their
ordinance their strikes and and come up
with the right answers and and maybe
unelect a few of the people
that they think are doing well that
aren't talked about transparency and the
way things are kind of wrecked and
messed up there a lot of people don't
understand the machinery of the house
the machinery of fundraising and the
requirements of this tell us a little
bit about what is usually required by
custom or by pointing the chest in terms
of your fundraising duties for the party
and etc okay money and politics is a
great example of one of those problems
that people know about but they don't
understand how the money is corrupting
the system the reality is there are 435
members of Congress 360 of them are safe
they could almost do anything and get
reelected so the question is how does
money corrupt them well they have to
raise money and give it to the party in
order to rent or buy their committee
assignments like literally the party
comes to you whether you're a Democrat
or Republican and says if you want an
important committee you're gonna have to
pay us this much money not one time but
every election cycle the you can't go
back to your district and ask your
constituents at a fundraiser to help you
buy a seat on a committee you get that
money from the lobbyists who are in
Washington DC now let me be clear I'm
not against lobbying as a profession
I'm not against my colleagues who pay
their dues that's a euphemism for
extortion who pay the extortion to the
NRCC in order to gain a better committee
assignment and to keep a better
committee assignment I'm calling out the
leaders in our party and in the other
party who've set up the structure that
causes people to become captive to the
lobbyists into that money who knocks on
your door how does that process work oh
they don't even knock on your door they
come on the floor of the House of
Representatives and they've got a little
assessment card and they'll slip it in
your pocket while you're voting and say
by the way Thomas you're $300,000
overdue we expect you to pay something
this quarter I mean call me crazy that
just sounds like a shakedown operation
it sounds like the Mafia it's a total
shakedown now again what they do with
the money is not a bad
thing people aren't buying Ferraris and
and yachts with that money in the
Republican Party they're trying to get
members elected in that party so they
can either keep the majority in the case
of the Republicans or take back the
majority in the case of the Democrats
it's again it's the incentive structure
and the way it influences behavior that
is wrong not what they do with the money
not the people who are there who have to
pay the extortion and not the lobbyists
who are able to provide the money so is
that why that all the people that you've
endorsed have turned out bad is that
they got caught up in that incentive
structure yeah it's too strong of a word
but like disappointing from what you
initially expected is it because they
responded to the institutional
incentives they're in the way that
people do it's kind of like The Hunger
Games the movie you like it seems like
an honor to represent your district but
then when you get placed on the island
you you realize you've got to grab
weapons you have to weaponize and you
are still running you have to compete
when you're there and so these these
folks get elected from their district
they come and they realize I'm gonna
have to weaponize I'm gonna have to get
a better committee assignment than the
person next to me and they do this maybe
not in the beginning because they're
morally compromised but because they
want to represent their constituents in
the best way they know how and they
believe that getting a more powerful
committee will let them represent their
constituents better so I don't blame
them for selling out I don't blame the
players but we've got to change the game
and the more people know about this
whether they're libertarian or democrat
or republican the more they can work
from the outside to change it they could
ask their Congressman how much do you
pay your party every every quarter to
keep that committee assignment so is
this like Serpico or whatever like do
they all hate you do all the crooked
cops hate the clean cop in this case
well you know I've exposed this on the
internet multiple times and in
interviews and nobody has once
challenged at least not on record with
the name maybe some anonymous Republican
aide might have challenged what I've
said but nobody with the name has ever
challenged what I've said and so they do
you become hated for breathing air next
to them
because you've exposed how this
incentive structure works partly because
they paid so much into this structure
right they got there and they've decided
to invest they've been good aim yeah
yeah they've got skin in the game and so
they they dislike you for that
and it's that and other things caused
them to dislike you for instance every
vote in the house is a voice vote until
one person objects at which point it
becomes a recorded vote of 435 members
now more than half a dozen times I've
been that person who stands up objects
demands a recorded vote on some issues
that people would rather not be recorded
on at that point they hate you for
breathing air and in the the pressure
it's like being deep underwater you
physically to have so many people around
you who hate you for being there it
constricts your chest and you take
shorter breaths and it's hard to breathe
Wow do I mean is it just the feel a
sense of seating or do they get up right
in your face and give you the business
in the cloakroom
it depends on the memory I have been
yelled at I've been screamed at usually
it's because they lost their cool and
they're come back they will come back
the next day and apologize but it's
mostly the people who don't say anything
that are most upset with you but they're
playing the game and they know part of
the game is never to show that you're
upset but you can feel it it's tangible
the leadership will call your donors and
tell them to quit giving you money and
they'll give a compelling argument why
they should quit giving you money they
will deny your bills a hearing in
committee or a vote on the floor they
will take your bills and give them to
somebody else who can put their name on
it and pass it what has that happened to
you
yeah this happened a couple of weeks ago
Walter Jones and I three years ago and
in two congresses have introduced a bill
to get rid of this perk that a Speaker
of the House enjoys after he's no longer
Speaker of the House the taxpayer has
four years since the seventies been
paying to keep an office Forex speakers
of the house they get they get a
full staff then get a postage budget and
they get an office inside of the Capitol
and they can still they can be an
outside lobbyist and still keep this
office that's crazy Denny Hastert milked
of more than a million dollars from the
taxpayer through through this office by
using this office and so we introduced a
bill to get rid of that we were told it
was spiteful toward the ex speaker which
it was nothing wrong with that somebody
wrote an article had said these two
Republicans are still trying to get rid
of John Boehner after he was no longer
the speaker we were obviously trying to
get rid of the office anyways we were
shut down stopped we tried it in an
amendment form we tried it as a
standalone bill at each step of the game
we were stopped and told no we're not
gonna let you get a vote and then a few
weeks ago Paul Ryan announced he had
slipped it into an appropriations bill
and this was part of his legacy was to
get rid of this office he was doing the
noble and right thing and they just I
mean Walter Jones was the primary
sponsor I was the secondary but he just
took our bill after telling us it was a
bad idea
and then claimed it as their own and to
add insult to injury they will raise
money for super PACs who will come to
our districts and say we were
ineffective uh
well I mean the point is you keep your
eye on the prize and you got a good
thing passed right your oh yeah I don't
mind that we don't get credit it's it's
when they go and say you didn't get
anything done right knowing that they
took your bill and there are other bills
I don't want to get into it for because
I'm I will engender more hate for
blowing the whistle on these folks
so you and Justin Amash are oftentimes
the guys to make sure that nothing gets
voiced voted and I think Rand Paul does
something similar he's often times the
only he's a one on several occasions
there and I know you're all friends and
you're the state mate with with with
Rand do you guys kind of have a target
on the back club like a little pity
party club do you just are you just
hitting shots and I don't know about
Amash but you and ran - hitting shots
and in the back how do you deal with
being pariahs in your own workplace you
know there's another interesting
phenomenon that goes on about once a
week or once every two weeks I will have
a member of Congress come to me and say
I just had a town hall and my
constituents asked me to be more like
you or to vote more like you sometimes
they come to me and say I've got a
couple kids and you're their favorite
congressman this is another congressman
speaking to us on the floor so not
everybody hates us we're not a pariah to
everybody in fact I believe that some of
them secretly wish that they could carve
out more space to vote their conscience
instead of voting the party or voting
the way that their funders want them to
vote and so secretly they wish they
could be more independent than they
really are as far as having a club the
great thing about having an an ideology
and a set of principles that's
consistent is you don't have to check in
with each other to know how the other
one's going to vote on an issue I can I
could go on a TV show at the same time
that Rand is on a TV show and Justin
Amash is on a TV show and without
talking to each other I'm pretty sure
we're going to be saying the same thing
about a bill and so it's convenient when
you don't have to get together and
include and say what's our story going
to be on this so is there any hope of
getting more of you felt like the the
wind was at the the back of people like
you back in 2010 2012 all the way up to
her maybe 2014 it seemed like the the
pool was growing it doesn't seem like
that anymore
is there any reinforcements on the
horizon you get a blue bird every
election cycle for instance I mentioned
Andy Biggs has been really good Matt
Gaetz has been really good we didn't I
didn't expect that I didn't know they
were going to be good it's almost like
the sort of the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle or the act of voting actually
determines how you're going to vote it's
impossible to know before somebody gets
there how they're going to respond to
all of the stimulus that they receive
and how they're eventually going to vote
and so we get a few and it's almost
seems random to me
we get a lot of Justin Amash ah's and
Rand Paul's and Thomas Massey's who I
think sell out in the first six months
they think they're going to do one thing
they believe it in their heart their
family knows that their constituents
know it and they end up doing something
else let's talk about something that's
important to all Americans which is
bourbon so we're starting trade Wars now
presumably you're not a fan of trade
wars although don't presume to speak
entirely for you you're certainly a fan
of bourbon and end of jobs you are
popular in your district the president
is popular in your district bourbon is
popular in your district and jobs are
popular in your district how is this
stuff playing out right now well trade
wars like violent Wars start in much the
same way right now it should be Congress
who decides when we're gonna initiate
some kind of tariff the founding fathers
never intended for one person in the
executive branch to pass a tax on every
American yet that's what's happening and
much like the executive branch has
usurped the power to make war which was
reserved to Congress the executive
branch is now has usurped the power to
make trade war and that's where we are
it's interesting the president used
national security as the justification
for the first shot in the trade war the
foreign countries reciprocated
retaliated and now we're retaliating but
the justification is you're allowed to
retaliate when you're when somebody
imposes an unfair tariff on you and so
this thing has escalated I say it's like
a bad divorce in a bad divorce both
spouses lose and the lawyer ends up with
more money in these pockets right in a
trade war both sets the citizens lose
and the government's end up with more
money in their pockets so yes I'm
against trade wars particularly when
they affect our bourbon in Kentucky you
know 95 percent of bourbon is from
Kentucky distilled there the other 5% is
counterfeit regardless what people tell
you this is a fact and so but here's the
interesting thing that I've observed a
lot of our bourbon brands
we're bought by foreign companies due to
our bad tax laws it made sense for a
foreign company to hold the brand
particularly before tax yeah before tax
reform now that's one of the things that
we fixed but I've got a brand in my
district I don't call out any Dame's
that's owned by a British company and so
when the EU decided to impose tariffs on
Kentucky Bourbon they actually they did
two things they raised the price of
bourbon for their own people in the
European Union and they also tariffed
one of their own companies and what this
shows you is how complicated tariffs are
in a global economy it's it's almost
impossible to see all all of the
permutations and and results of tariffs
but when you balance the equations and
reduce the fractions and figure out who
wins and loses it's always the customer
that sees a higher price do you have a
sense of what the damage could be just
to the Bourbon industry because it's so
it's a closer to you well you know I
think the elasticity of demand for
bourbon is different than the elasticity
of demand for steel and whatnot and
where it comes from
people are still going to want to drink
Kentucky bourbon it's a bargain at twice
the price right so I think there people
will still pay for for bourbon and
hopefully it won't affect us that much
we're told this is a bloodletting that
eventually this will stop and it will
result in zero tariffs on both sides
here's the problem with that I mean I
hope that's the case I hope we get fewer
tariffs for our products going into
other countries and then eventually our
tariffs ie taxes go away but we're also
being told this will protect American
businesses and that manufacturing for
instance steel will come back to the
United States
well what CEO is going to start a new
factory based on the story that it's
only going to be profitable and when
there is a tariff and that this tariff
is going to go away as soon as possible
yeah nobody's going to open a new
business based on that they might keep a
business that's marginal or about to
fail in business for a few more months
nobody's gonna start a new endeavor and
invest capital based on a decision
that's made by one executive and that
executive says we're gonna I may change
my decision tomorrow do I mean not to be
rude about the sitting president of the
United States but do you get the sense
that he understands international trade
I am going to say that his intuition on
some of these things is right and what's
I will tell you that I I do not like the
fact that Congress is now subservient to
the World Trade Organization everything
that you purchase has a country of
origin labeling label on it like this
suit and tells you that it wasn't made
in America your your phone will say
where it's made your fruits and
vegetables your fish but Congress we
were told a few years ago that the World
Trade Organization had ruled and we were
going to have to remove country of
origin labeling from beef and pork
because it created a hardship for cattle
and pigs that were coming from Canada
and from Mexico and I I don't like that
fact this is these are not judges at the
World Trade Organization that are
appointed by Congress by elected
officials and so when the president
speaks about going more to bilateral
agreements than a multilateral agreement
which requires some kind of world
government not to sound conspiratorial
but that's what it is it's a world court
heavily tilted in the favor of the
United States who wins almost all the
disputes what we mean we lost the one
with Canada and Mexico will be losing
some in the near future I have no doubt
so I don't know let's see this you know
what we've got a great test case I could
be wrong things could turn out
wonderfully the tariffs could go away
you know let me let me say something
else too if and and this upsets some
libertarians so it's kind of says
smiling yes again but is it is it worse
to tax production than it is to tax
consumption I don't think you can make
the case that it
more moral to tax your labor than it is
to tax your consumption of foreign goods
so in the beginning of our country
ninety percent of the revenues for our
country came from tariffs now if you so
if you wanted to replace the income tax
if you wanted to repeal the 16th
amendment and replace it with a flat
tariff I could entertain that the
problem with the Selective tariffs is
now you've walked into the area of
central planning yeah and now you're
pretending that the Department of
Commerce just like some department in
the Soviet Union would know better
whether we need more steel or less steel
in this country whether we need more
steel plants or less steel plants it
sounds like FDR it sounds like the
Soviet Union
it sounds like China although they're in
some ways more capitalist than we are on
these issues and so I don't like
selective tariffs from a central
planning standpoint there's another
problem that I'm witnessing firsthand in
Congress with tariffs that is you can
apply for an exemption to a tariff if
your company endures some hardship
that's going to put it out of business
well you can send Wilbur Ross a letter
and fill out the form and go to the
website and there I think at least
10,000 exemption applications right now
it's certainly in the thousands so we
recently had a meeting with about 30
congressman and secretary Ross and 28 of
the 30 congressmen were there to ask
secretary Ross for a special exemption
for a company in their district who had
applied for the exemption now you are in
the area of cronyism absolutely I don't
like to call it crony capitalism because
it's not capitalism it's its markets
being driven by favors that the more
access you have the fewer taxes ie
tariffs you would have to pay and that's
the the sort of race to the bottom that
you get into interesting it reminds me
of you know heavily zoned or heavily
regulated local zoning ordinances and
the types of places which I live unlike
your off-the-grid farm yeah I end up
living in Los Angeles Washington or New
York so they're super heavily regulated
and what do you do if you are
person or a company you spend all your
life going to City Hall getting
exemptions getting variances of the
zoning regulations and that's the
friction that makes a lot of kind of
money flow in politics and it just seems
like a lot of wasted effort and the and
it also you've just made me worry about
the present moment even more it sounds
like a built-in incentive structure for
Congress critters including people
who've spent their lives talking about
the virtues of free trade well now
there's the virtues of doing a favor for
your constituents and looking like the
you know the the white knight and a
horse right which is a bad it's a little
worse than that because yeah these
congressmen were advocating on behalf of
their constituents so they might get
some credit for that exemption that the
executive branch and the executive
branch alone grants but at the end of
the day you are enriching the executive
branch frankly at the expense of the
congressional legislative branch because
it's the executive branch that can issue
those variances so now they they become
more powerful because they can issue
variances to these tariffs it's a it's a
really bad situation like I said if you
wanted a flat 10% tariff on every
product coming into this country and you
got rid of the income tax that might not
be such a bad thing but by allowing
variances by picking which segments of
the economy are going to be taxed and
which ones aren't you are enriching and
empowering the executive branch which is
a very dangerous thing so let's find
some place for optimism because I'm
feeling like I need it after the end of
this conversation are you getting are
you is there something good on the
horizon that's happening some kind of
reform criminal justice are you
legalizing hemp what are you doing what
are they prop the prospects for a good
thing happening kind of under the radar
right now I think the federal
prohibition on the marijuana plant will
be gone within a decade oh and it's it's
not going to be because of any bravery
on the part of legislators that I serve
with the states are taking the lead and
if you remember that's how we got rid of
the 55 mile an hour federal speed limit
if some state said now this is
ridiculous and so people started driving
faster and we found out it actually
is just fine and I think the same things
going to happen
with the federal prohibition on the
marijuana plant within a decade if the
vote were today the federal prohibition
would go away it's just a slim number of
people in leadership in Congress that
are keeping that vote from happening in
so a change in leadership could mean
that issue gets resolved tomorrow
so there's who is a prospective leader
who would put that to a vote
oh the Jim Jordan put that to a vote um
I don't know if he would put his I don't
know what his personal feelings are on
that issue and if we would put a finger
on the scale of that he would be far
more likely to let the body do its will
then Paul Ryan is right now Paul Ryan's
been worse than John Boehner in terms of
allowing individual members of Congress
to have a part in the process far worse
bob Corker in the Senate gave a speech
about a month ago talking about how we
just don't vote on anything anymore like
it's the voting has stopped nothing gets
to the floor the same kind of
bottlenecking that's happening and I
wonder since we're talking about
incentives and complaining in general
about Congress abdicating all its basic
responsibilities what is what's the
structural incentive for Mitch McConnell
and Chuck Schumer and and and Paul Ryan
and John Boehner and everybody to act in
this one and see Pelosi and Nancy Pelosi
thank you to act in this way it seems
you know you can ryan was supposed to be
marginally better than Boehner and you
and other people say that he's worse on
this specific issue but there must be
some kind of reward system that's making
that happen what is it okay I told you
there's a dus system for members of
Congress who want a better committee
assignment there's an assessment and
it's in the hundreds of thousands of
dollars to get or keep a better
committee seat the assessment on a
speaker is in the tens of millions if
the speaker is expected to raise fifty
to a hundred million dollars every
election cycle for the party god that
comes with some encumbrances to the
donors if you can imagine fifty to a
hundred million dollars of encumbrances
and there are other incentive for
short-circuiting the
the power of the house is when when they
when they short-circuit the legislative
process and there are only four people
in the room writing the bill those four
people become more powerful now
oftentimes at the expense of the power
of the legislative branch but they are
trading our power as legislators to the
executive branch so that each of them
can have more power so that they can go
to the White House they sit down okay
what do you want in this appropriations
bill okay that's what we'll put in it
and then after four people write a two
thousand and three hundred page bill
it's brought back to us and we have
eight hours to read it and vote on it
and so they have way more power the
leadership in Congress does then if
there were an open process how do you
avoid just saying America you're drunk
go home you know how what makes you want
to continue in this line of work besides
the cushy job and benefits the cushy job
and benefits yes as you know I had a
very good livelihood in the private
sector and this is not a cushy job and
it's I've turned down most of the
benefits I like the health care and
whatnot so what makes me want to do it
I do see results look we did force John
Boehner out now we got somebody who was
worse but at the end of the day the
swamp did not want him to leave they
were in full-out panic for a few weeks
until they figured out how they're gonna
patch everything up the fact that you
can occasionally cause the swamp to go
into a full panic shows me that there is
hope bringing transparency to the
process I want the American people to be
equipped with the knowledge they need to
advocate for things that will fix
Congress constitutional convention I'm
sorry is not going to fix Congress my
colleagues don't follow the Constitution
we've got they're not going to follow a
new one term limits I'm like co-sponsor
to term limit bills I will vote for them
they will not fix the problems we have
and so I have hope I have optimism in
that when the American people get the
information that I've been able to
obtain by being behind the curtain that
they will start advocating
for things that will fix the process
very good well thank you very much for
talking with us today congressman Thomas
Massie for reason I am Matt well
[Music]